let's go with another e4 and let's go
for another danish if he plays e5 okay
goes b6 this is called the owens game or
the owens defense
and it's it's not a terrible opening
but it's the kind of opening you only
want to play
if you know exactly what you're doing
because if you don't you can lose
very very quickly so obviously we go d4
as we often do and we we you don't
reinvent the wheel just go knight c3
okay he could have gone bishop a6 whoa
38 another five thank you damn girl
lots of support this morning i love it
thank you
okay now how should we how should we
develop our pieces and
this can be a little bit tricky for
players because
if you look at this bishop it's not
entirely clear where it can go
i mean bishop b5 just looks incredibly
awkward bishop c4
just bites on granite bishop d3 just
stares at this pawn
and yet that is the square you want to
choose bishop d3 is where you want to
put the bishop y
because you want to make sure this pawn
is very well protected that is super
important
because black is going with bishop b4 on
the next move
and that's going to put this pawn under
significant pressure because
black will threaten to take the knight
and then take the pawn in addition
why is the bishop on d3 it has a lot of
potential energy and the reason for that
is because
white can go e5 at a later point and
open up the bishop's
diagonal and if black castle sure you
can already kind of smell a greek gift
sacrifice in the works
i'm jumping the gun here but you see
what i'm saying
bishop b4 is what we're expecting he can
also yeah there should be four
okay now let me remember the theory here
just give me a second
yeah so there's a couple of moves here
as far as i remember i analyzed this
pretty recently
actually um but
again there's there's many ways for
white to get an advantage but there's a
line that i found recently which is not
necessarily the best line but it's
really really interesting so queen g4 is
absolutely a legit move
i'll talk about it after the game it's
not as good as it seems because black
has a very strong response
so we don't want to reinvent the wheel
we just want to analyze our analyze our
pieces develop our pieces here
so what's the simplest way of developing
our pieces the absolute simplest
no frills and we need to figure out if
we we have to do anything about this pin
as i've said many many times you don't
need to play bishop d2 in such positions
because
we are not afraid of him taking on c3
that pawn structure deficiency
is just not an issue because
we we'd eliminate this very important
bishop
and if anything it's kind of good to
have pawns on c3 and d4 it supports the
pawn on d4
so the simplest is to go knight after
just develop your knight that's
precisely why we put the bishop on d3 we
don't have to worry about this pawn
being weak
now we do have to worry about this bond
being weak
and there's a couple of options we can
push this pawn to e5
immediately but that allows the sort of
nasty response
knight to e4 using this pen the knight
is untouchable
so it's better to defend this pawn one
more time
now a lot of you might be thinking about
bishop to g5 here let's pin the knight
and in that way let's stop the knight
from moving but who can tell me why
bishop g5 is inaccurate here
this is a very common mistake thinking
that this pin
is a good way of defending a pawn on e4
so he goes h6
and what if bishop h4 there then he goes
g5
attacking the bishop the bishop has to
move and then we drop the pawn on e4
and the weakening of his king side is
not reason enough
to give up the super important central
punk we need to is much better
this is all theory and
the the theoretical move is is to play
d5 which is very
very natural yeah knight g2 is an option
as well
and i will be very uh honest and say
that i
i don't remember my analysis so i'm just
going off of sort of off of instinct
you are welcome to sort of analyze this
with an engine and i'm sure that you can
find the best line
white is better here with best play i
can check uh negi's book afterward
to see what he recommends okay d5
now we locked the center here we don't
want to take on d5 because he can even
take with the queen
and his bishop on b7 is going to come
alive so we certainly don't want to
close down
the bishop
okay and now yours knight have d7 that
is not the best move
the best move here is to go knight e4
and i'll talk about that after the game
knight e4 would have been far more
challenging now
what should we do here what should we
play
so yeah so castles is fine
that's one of the one of the
possibilities there is
a little bit of a nasty move that you
can make here which is c5
but i'll talk about it if you place it
we have i have a response cooked up for
that
a3 would have would have possibly been a
slightly more precise move he goes h6 so
he doesn't
doesn't do anything but knight g5 also
was very interesting but i want to play
it a little bit more simply
okay so how should we what should the
general plan here
well it should be clear that our play
should be on the king side
and in the long run we should be trying
to activate our queen
and get our queen for example to g4 so
one
possibility is just to drop the knight
back and then get our queen of g4
but i also kind of like the idea of
forcing him to
decide what he's asking him a question
let's tickle his bishop
and if he takes on c3 that's really good
for us because then this bishop
is going to be uncontested if he drops
his bishop back we don't have to deal
with the headache of his bishop being on
before i don't know if that makes sense
yeah 405 is a great idea okay so he
takes i
i love seeing that and he goes c5
now what's the threat what what is he
threatening here
and you ha and in the owen defense you
have to be super careful about this he
is threatening to go c4
and trap our bishop it's not that easy
to stop
but there is a way to now what is a way
to stop it what can we do what type of
move can we make here
so if we place c4 ourself then we allow
him to take
and open his bishop i don't want to do
that so what we can do is we can move
our queen
and allow the bishop to drop back to e2
thank you andrus
some of you are saying bishop b5 but
then he can play a6
and we'd have to trade this bishop and
we don't want to trade it that light
squared bishop
is incredibly important it's important
as an attacker so let's go queen e3 why
queen e3 because we're
simultaneously supporting the the d4
pawn so if he plays knight c6 then we
don't have to worry about it as much
now obviously there's a little bit of
awkwardness here with our development
this bishop is sort of blocked but
that's all temporary remember what i
said about peace placement the other day
peace placement is usually temporary if
you're worried about one of your pieces
blocking another
that is a problem that you are generally
capable of solving
so we have a plan in this position think
about
where this queen would belong i
previously said thank you so much andres
i appreciate it
where would this queen want to be well
it would want to be somewhere on the g
file
because it would then be attacking g7
that should be pretty self-evident
so what is our next move very likely to
be if he doesn't play c4
what is our next move very likely to be
our next two moves
okay queen f4 and queen g3 exactly
or we could drop our knight back but our
knight is kind of good on f3 it's
defending d4
so queen f4 is a grey maneuver here
queen f okay he plays a very good move
bishop a6
he's he is trading the bishop so that's
not something we can do anything about
let's go queen f4 anyway
and then we want to drop our queen to
either g4 or g3
in order to attack the pawn on g7
this guy is legit he's he's playing this
quite well i have to say
does it matter which of these two moves
we make not as much i like queen g4
because
it just seems to be a bit of a more
aggressive posture
and the queen on g4 would maintain its
defense over the d4 pawn
so if he plays knight c6 this knight
would be free to move
if we would want to prepare f4 f5 at
some point
now again do we care about these pawns
being doubled no in fact we like that
because if he ever takes on d4 and we
take back
what would we gain from the fact that
this pawn has repositioned to d3
why could that be a good thing for white
yeah we would have the c file so in case
he castles lung which is
a very common idea in the owen we would
be able to attack the king
no matter where it went now of course if
he castle short here that would be a
horrible move
because the bishop takes h6 that's a
very very simple tactic his best move
would probably be just to go g6 although
it is extremely weakening
and then we would need to develop this
bishop
so i would propose bishop e3 as a simple
move
now if you play the french with white he
goes king of faith
now that i think is a mistake so let's
develop our bishop
let's develop our bishop and now we have
a very very clear plan
i've talked about this one what should
be our attacking plan
what should be our attacking plan yeah
we should try to play f45
blast through the king side even if we
have to sacrifice something on f5 if we
can open up the app file
we will be very likely to check my head
now
we need to think about where we want to
put the knight and
knight h4 seems very tempting because
when we play f4 f5 this knight is going
to be a participant in the attack
there is a drawback to knight h4 which
is that he can chase that knight away
with the g5
which which can be a very annoying move
in these positions and it appears that
we'd have to bring the knight back to f3
now in reality we can play knight h4 and
then sacrifice the knight if he goes g5
but we'll cross that bridge when we get
there
there's a very interesting okay knight
e7
so that's a great move yeah this guy is
good this guy's very good
um so knight h4
g5 so he's controlling the f5 square
that's this whole idea
which is why we basically need to start
playing on many sides on
on multiple sides of the board okay
so i would propose the simple mover gate
rookie to c1 for now
occupying the c file let's see how he
positions his pieces
and then plan accordingly so knight f5
for example
we could set up a plan to try to chase
the knight away with g4
yeah guys no no accusations obvious okay
so we want to play g4 to chase away this
knight
why can't we play g4 well the queen is
sitting on g4
where would we want to put our queen
remember that one of the key principles
behind where the queen should be placed
that we want the queen to be sort of out
of the way we don't want the queen to
stumble on its own pieces so queen f4
here would allow
g5 so we want to bring the queen back to
h3 it's perfectly fine there
it's somewhat invulnerable it's hard to
chase and the move g4 isn't that really
weakening it is
but his king is also on the king side so
it's not like he can really attack
us there i don't know if that makes
sense but
a lot of players are afraid of making a
move like g4 but remember all of our
pieces are there
it's very unlikely that we're going to
pay the price for it
yeah exactly no no andres you're fine
you're cool you're cool so he takes
which is good because it opens up the f
file for us unless he plays king g8 that
would be a very good move
okay
i mean this guy is definitely much much
stronger than his rating but plenty of
people are stronger than their writing
all right so now
the file is open but we have to modify
our plan because we can no longer play
f4 5. he's done our work for us so what
plan
uh naturally stems from the f file being
open what should be our plan
you guys are thinking about these very
tactical moves but what's a more
methodical way of putting pressure on
the spawn
well eventually we'd have to move the
knight but before we move the knight
we can double our row stack our rooks
and
there is this phrase interest the threat
is stronger than its execution
and that applies here stacking your
rooks may seem kind of stupid why would
we stack our rooks when the knight is on
f3
oh i have to turn off my copyright for
one second guys we have a tactic here
we have a tactic here try to think of it
no i don't know what that leap was
we have a tactic here we don't even need
to stack our rooks
we don't even need to stack a rooks now
many of you
are noticing that if our knight was gone
if our knight was gone from f3 we would
have
what move and many of you are already
spawning
we would have queen take c6 now
that what naturally stems from that is
the is the knight takes g5 idea
knight takes g5 is very very strong
because he can't play h takes g5
obviously the rook hangs if he plays
queen takes g5
we snap snap up the pawn on e6 this is
not winning
at least this is not immediately winning
we're attacking the knight we're
attacking the pawn on f7
this check on e3 would be very
counterproductive
because his queen would be far away from
the kang and the king is getting mated
he has to find queen e7 that is the only
defensive move
that prolongs the game and i think
there's a very instructive move
after queen e7 no he takes so that's
very tempting but it's bad and some of
you may even see queen takes c1 trying
to distract the rook from the f-file
maybe that's what he's relying on but
what happens after queen takes c1
why is that not like winning for black
because of course we take on f7 and
that's still made even though a piece is
pinned
it can still defend another piece just
as a rule clarification
he's busted here he can still defend
with rook h7
which is the only move here but then we
take his knight and and then material is
equal and we have a devastating attack
on the king
so there's a lot to unpack in this game
for sure
okay so
[Music]
yeah i'll talk about queen e7 after the
game
i'll talk about queen e7 after the game
i'm going to try in the meantime to find
an instructive example of
the concept that i'm going to reveal
yeah pin piece a pin piece cannot itself
move but it can defend another piece
i have a very funny story about that and
i've shared this story before
i've shared the story before but it's a
funny story about that rule that a pin
piece
can defend another piece so he can't
take my queen if queen takes f7 mate
yeah i have a funny funny story about
that which was pretty terrifying at the
time
so okay he's thinking here
he's totally busted his only move is
rook h7 and then we take the knight we
win
yeah but tactics like knight takes g5
right they stem pretty naturally from
the position
you already have your eyes peeled for
tactics when you've got a pin going on
the king like that
and that's what a lot of people have to
try a lot harder to do it's like you've
got to be super proactive about
making the right observations okay
what's going on here do i notice any
pins
when those thoughts swirl around in your
brain it's far more likely that you're
going to spot various tactics
and even if you were to double your
rooks there that would be totally
totally totally fine as well so here he
can't take my queen right that's the
whole concept
even though the rook is pinned it still
defends the queen
by rule and
the story that i have to share concerns
the game which in which i became an i am
so the game where i became an i am i was
playing a grand master this was 2011 and
i had to draw this game
in order to become an i am and i managed
to win this game
because my opponent blundered a knight
in one move if you want to see a gm
blundering a knight in one move
here you go another five by 38 oh my god
stop it
so here's a funny here's part one of
this story
so we got this very complicated end game
i'm playing black i'm down a pawn i've
got some piece activity
and my opponent no my opponent had
plenty of time here he thought for 15
minutes
he plays the move h5 he blunders a
knight in one move so gm's do blunder
their pieces sometimes
um and i got very very lucky
um so that happens and eventually and of
course the win is very easy here
i converted the advantage and in this
final position i played rookie two check
and this is the winning move because
after king c1
rookie won he moves this game and i
promote with checkmate
so he takes his king and he takes my
rook which is kind of hilarious
i mean it doesn't allow me to make the
move because it's an illegal move and he
presses the clock and i'm like oh my god
did i just blunder did i forget the
rules because my knight is obviously
pinned
then he laughed and he shook my hand and
he resigned and the funny thing is i
would still be winning
even if he took my rook i could i could
simply promote my queen
it was still funny though and i was
terrified for like five seconds
um anyways so now to the game
so d4 bishop b7 knight c3 nagi
recommends
e6 he gives knight so he gives knight f3
yeah he basically gives this via
transposition
and now he gives queen e2 yep queen e2
d5 oh very interesting
wow so he gives a very interesting move
in this position
um he gives the move castles
which looks like a huge blunder
beca well why does this look like a
blunder
this looks like a big blunder because it
appears that it loses a piece
to bishop takes c3 and if b takes e3
then d takes e4 wins
a piece and of course this pawn is
defended twice
and attacked twice so it cannot be taken
but the key is an intermediate move in
this position now you play e5
counter attack in the knight and the
point
is that if black just moves the bishop
out of c3
after e takes f6 it appears that black
simply wins the pawn
but if you're familiar with these types
of positions you
will be familiar with this trick bishop
g5 traps the queen
which is kind of funny and if
black plays g takes f6 that's the main
line white plays the move knight h4
so white's basically preparing moves
like knight f5 and queen h5
this is upon sacrifice line but white
gets obvious and very very serious
compensation
oh sorry sorry first you play c3 bishop
e7 c3 first
you get the bishop out of the way and
then you play knight h4
so the idea is to play queen h5 here
yeah this is very much so black
black's main move according to him is h5
himself to prevent queen h5
rookie one piling up along the e file
queen to d7 b4 starting an attack on the
queen side knight c6 bishop d2
and white gets extremely nice
compensation for the pawn
um a5 a3 etc but he's got another
recommendation which is to play
the non-pawn sacrifice line is e5 and
cast oh that's another font sacrifice
line hilarious
so basically you go for this position
and then you strike with bishop g5 and
strike and strike so anyways
this is a novelty um his analysis is
very deep here i don't want to read out
all of it it'll take me like an hour
but yeah but like uh
you can take it from here and analyze
with an engine
this is the beginning of his
recommendation bishop g5 counter
attacking his queen
so we we went for the main line which
was queen e2 uh d5 and then e5
okay this is e4 versus minor defenses
that's like volume
four of the e4 series by negi
um all right so
the main move here as far as i remember
is knight e4
and my idea was to sacrifice upon here
the most obvious move is bishop d2 and
that's not very good right he takes the
bishop he has the two bishop advantage
this is a very awkward situation another
five by thirty oh my god this guy is
like gifting
like 800 subs here another five by 38.
i wonder if he's gonna give a total of
38 subs
this is crazy thanks man i really
appreciate it
and what makes this very awkward is that
white doesn't have the move c3 in the
french white can defend against this
with c3 here the pawn chain kind of
collapses
because y can't play c3 thank you man
really appreciate it so i was planning
to simply castle
and after knight c3 bc bishop takes c3
so why have engines not made such books
obsolete well
opening books get outdated a lot faster
now but naegi is using an
engine and i discussed earlier the
concept of seconds right
analyzing openings is not simply a
matter of
you know leaving an engine on a position
for 10 minutes if that was the case then
anybody could write an opening book
sometimes engines can still be wrong
sometimes you have to choose between
five engine recommendations that are
approximately equivalent
you have to choose the line that's
that's the best practically and that's
where these very strong players come in
um okay so in this position
um we can go rogue b1 and in return for
the pawn we have
beautifully placed pieces black's king
is in huge trouble
because of black castles and of course
white's got the greek gift sacrifice
sort of a classic great gift
and if white black doesn't castle then
as many of you recommended we have
knight g5 and queen h5
this just seems very good for us we can
also go bishop a3 in some of these
positions to
keep the king confined to the center so
to me this seems like a very good
practical practical weapon i don't know
if that makes sense
there's a ton of compensation for the
fun
i'm pretty sure that if black analyzes
this with an engine perhaps
black is fine there but practically
speaking i like this idea
so he went knight fd7 we castle
and here i think that h6 is probably a
little bit too slow
i think that c5 is a more testing
weapon here because black threatens to
go c4 and black also threatens to break
up white's pawn chain
and a3 for example would lead to
disaster after bishop take c3 and c4 i'm
pretty sure i've even fallen into that a
couple times
so what would we have done here well one
option is to go
for broke with knight g5 that would be
that would be interesting
and the idea here is that after c4 we
could even try to sacrifice on e6 or you
could play queen f3
threatening checkmate and paving uh a
little pathway for the bishop back to e2
so that's something we could have gone
for after h6 we play a3
and of course this is no longer that
scary first of all we've got the pawn
chain second of all we can move our
queen out of the way
and prevent or take the sting out of c4
okay so bishop a6 queen f4 transferring
the queen to the g
file or yeah to the g file queen g4
king f8 bishop e3 get the bishop out
first and here black plays a very nice
move knight e7
so let's imagine the black didn't play
97 let's imagine the black played a non
like a neutral move such as rook c8 so
we would have gone knight h4
as i explained f4 f5 is the idea yeah
this seems like a win hour this is a
very french-like structure
so these two openings are very related
and
let's say that black plays the move g5
here
in this position i had cooked up a
sacrifice
a very interesting sacrifice who can
spot
this very interesting move
and this has to do with what i call the
samwell
sam shanklin calls it that the sam
shanklin question so when you have an
idea the first
thing you have to ask yourself is and
and your opponent
tries to prevent that idea what happens
if i do it anyway
what happens if i play the move i want
it to play even though there's some sort
of threat
because sometimes the idea is so strong
that you can literally
ignore the threat and the idea still
works so i think the move f4 at least
from a practical standpoint
is incredibly strong simply f4 and then
f5
and because the f file gets open just
intuitively you should notice how
dangerous this is for black
just do it anyway he takes f5 rook takes
f5 then we double rooks
38 with another five oh my god this is
crazy folks
this guy is just not stopping um
and this is crushing i mean look at all
these pieces involved in the attack
knights are pretty bad defenders
um of specific weaknesses you know like
a bishop can multitask a bishop can
defend a weakness
and control other squares knights are
not good at multitasking they can really
only do one thing at a time
that's why when you've got a weakness on
f7 like this
knights are just they're stumbling
around each other and this is just very
bad
why not take with the queen because
paradoxically taking with the queen
i think is worse because when the queen
and i've talked about this before when
the queen is in front of the other
pieces
that's like sending out napoleon
bonaparte or like your war general to
fight on the front lines you want the
queen directing the effort from
an unobtrusive place such as h5 so that
the rooks can have their moment in the
sun on the f-file
and the ultimate problem is going to
come down to the fact that you're not
going to be able to take f7 because
that's going to lead to a queen trade
if you've had your rooks doubled instead
then obviously you can take on f7
i hope that makes sense by the way i
don't know if that concept makes sense
but
you can let me know
okay so e6 after yeah no this is still
winning no no you're right this is still
winning e6 is very strong this is
totally still winning
but i'm talking about this more
conceptually okay
great so it makes sense so f4 would have
been a very interesting try but he plays
a nice move 97
so he he realizes that f5 is a key
square to control
and the same idea would not be effective
here because now he's controlling f5
with two pieces
f5 would involve sacrificing another
exchange and that's just a little bit
too much
it would still be kind of interesting
that this is not over we have an f-file
attack but i just feel like white
doesn't have
quite enough material uh to warrant this
okay so we went rook ac one and this is
a move which
some people struggle with right what
this involves is taking a step back and
seeing the bigger picture
um when you are playing on one side of
the board you don't want to have this
tunnel vision
and make this into like an end-all
be-all
you can still make healthy improving
moves on other sides of the board
and that's a way of sort of diversifying
your investment portfolio
if you're attacking on the king side you
want to prepare for the eventuality that
things fail
that you don't succeed in getting the
attack started and if that happens
then getting a rook to an open file is
going to be a great idea
if black ever starts playing on the
queen side we're going to be a little
bit more well prepared for that
so i hope that also kind of makes sense
so we wait for him to go knight f5 and
only now do we drop our queen back
and prepare to chase this knight away
now i think knight e3 was a big mistake
i think that he
he had been playing well thus far black
is definitely worse here
i think one thing he could have done is
brought the king to g8 and
only after g4 taking on e3 is already a
much better scenario for black
still black is worse we have the c file
under control we've got the f file now
but black can defend here black is
careful i think that he shouldn't get
checkmated here i think he's kind of
fine
okay so knight e3
helps white and now g5 is just way too
weakening he should have still gone king
g8
and black is still doing okay here one
idea here is to go rook c6 and prepare
sacrifice on e6 but g5 is literally
asking for it
so the process of pattern recognition i
think starts with realizing
that you're pinning his f pawn so you
should already be
primed to look at ideas that involve a
move like queen takes e6
right and even if you're 1100 or
whatever your rating is
this is not rocket science this is just
something that you should see if you've
ever seen this pattern before
um and so if you're trying to get your
queen to e6 you have to move the knight
well if you move the knight to d2 then
that's like telegraphing a pass in
basketball you're basically telling your
opponent all right i'm threatening queen
takes e6
so you're giving him an opportunity to
defend so that's why where sacrifices
come and sacrifices are like a way of
distracting your opponent
forcing him to deal with the immediate
threat
so he has to take the knight and that in
turn allows us to
execute our idea
but again even if you had decided to
stack your rooks up
white is still very much dominating
because the queen could slide in
up to h5 and pressure the pawn as well
so black is in huge trouble
so knight g5 takes takes now queen e3
loses the game
he had to go back to e7 now what do you
what do you guys think white should do
here and when i said that this is
instructive it's not instructive because
there's some beautiful move here
actually to the contrary
so i think very often when people are
attacking
and this is also a form of tunnel vision
they assume that
every move has to be a sacrifice that
every move has to somehow
advance the cause of attacking and so
rook f7
would be a move that comes to mind um
to that end and it's it's a pretty good
move queen f7 rook f1
but after something like rook h7
defending the queen if you take the
queen
you know what black's got a lot of
mike's got a lot of stuff for the queen
black's got two rooks in a night
white's got a gazillion ponds and i
think white is still winning
but it's not as clear-cut as i would
like it
and um queen takes d7 here may seem like
an improvement
because you take the knight first and
the queen is still pinned but it's
actually a huge blunder
who can tell me why
yeah queen f1 is a very typical tactical
idea eliminating
the rook that's giving the pin the
network takes d7 wins the queen
so don't do that but it's much simpler
to play queen takes d5 here
so as my coach would always say prepare
slowly attack fast
but sometimes you can attack slowly too
yes you're down a piece
but you've got a million pounds who's to
say you can't take a moment to take a
very important pawn
and sort of reorganize your attacking
forces so for example if he moves his
rook
a very big temptation here would be to
go e6 gotta made him immediately but
then that allows knight f6
a much more methodical move would be to
slide the rook into c7 and maybe even
take the pawn on a7
so when you're attacking you have to
realize
that checkmate is not the only outcome
of a successful attack
very often players struggle with the
idea i think of transforming an attack
into a material advantage
so against really good defenders that's
one of the things that you have to learn
to do
is to realize that when you're attacking
sometimes you have to transform the
attack even into a slightly better end
game that might be
um the only way to quote unquote succeed
in the attack so in any case
that's um that's something to to to to
keep your eyes on and remember
i'm trying to find an example of that
but
i'm kind of struggling let me see
okay so
moment sorry
okay
so i have an example of this this is not
the best example but it's also really
cool
from a tactical standpoint so i'm gonna
show you guys
uh this example anyway yes happy
mother's day to you as well
okay ask me if i care
all right one second i gotta
there
sorry my chest base is like very
seriously glitching
chess base is not made for streaming
okay we're good
should be fine
so this game is from the london chess
classic oh my god this guy gifted
another five subs
this is unbelievable thanks man i really
appreciate it
this is just phenomenal stuff right here
the hype is real folks
oh and another sub by heisenberg wolf
there we go love it love it love it
thank you
all right so let's see
um
so yeah um yeah i've gained two points
in five years
but it's hard chess improvement is hard
at this level so no shame
thank you rusdan there we go there's a
hype train
okay so this is a game
that i played in the london classic 2014
i was i had to flew this tournament so i
was just
barely able to function at the board but
this last game i played was still really
nice
um now we see a position where
there's a sicilian and black's king is
just
very weak here the rook is pinning the
king and i decided to just converge on
this king i brought all of my pieces in
the attack knight d5
queen f4 and now i found a very nice
way to rip open his defenses
white to play and this after i played
this move i thought the game would end
in like three moves i honestly thought
this ended the game
well not knight e7 that that is defended
knight f6
knight f6 takes takes
and he couldn't not take the knight
because it's a fork against his rook
and i thought this was it i thought
there was a lobster pincer mate coming
he can sack his knight for the pawn but
that doesn't help
if he takes on f6 we can give a check on
g5 first and then take on f6 of the rook
but i completely missed this move c4
this is a really nice defensive resource
what this move allows him to do is
potentially bring his queen in
either to c5 or to e5
this also covers the g5 square where i
was planning to deliver
a check so i play queen h6 and he
sacrifices back the knight exactly at
the right time
now if he would have gone queen c5 and
queen fa that was not good
because here i can just step back to g5
and then take
you know and then take h5 or go e5 and
get the bishop involved so i was not
worried about that
but after he gives the knight back he
simply goes queen to d8
he throws water onto the fire and
now he gives me a check on d4 and now
he's got the possibility of involving
his queen in the defense via queen g7 so
the attack really kind of wanes here
now he goes ruxin and prepares an attack
of his own he prepares to go rook c2
so in such situations
this is where it's very important to
sort of switch gears
and i had a big temptation at first
to look for sort of bizarre and crazy
attacking ideas i was considering rook
f6
then i realized that it's all hope chess
i actually don't have any ways
to to continue the attack per se
um i thought about e5 here doesn't do
anything either thank you super
black sea for the prime so i was able in
this game to really switch
my mindset completely and realize that
the best thing to do here and i played
rook for a k5 on the next move
but the best thing to do here is just to
go after the material
so what's the simplest move in the
position sometimes it pays
to play very simple chess
so queen takes h5 simply take the pawn
he goes rook c2 and now i go rook a5
so this is an attacking move trying to
get my rook to g5
but my opponent blocks the rook with b5
and now i was very proud of the move
that i played
because precisely because it is so
simple
we simply take another pawn we play rook
takes a6 and i say the attack is over
so what i have to do now is understand
that i'll simply be up a pawn
queen takes e4 now my opponent jumps
onto the offensive
queen g5 check king f8
and now i was able to find a very nice
tactical way
to make sure that his attack fizzles out
and transform the position into sort of
a technical win
and the key here is understanding that
this king is incredibly vulnerable
so you can weaponize the fork you can
use the fork
as a defensive tool and come up with a
really cool defensive idea so a lot of
you are spotting queen c5 that's the
right idea
but after rooks e5 bishop b4 he takes on
b3
and it's time to offer a draw because
material is equal
but when you have this kind of idea you
should ask yourself how can i use the
idea of queen c5
but modify it a little bit what move can
we play first
well queen h6 i just came from there
queen h6 i just came from there this
repeats move so i can make a draw
but notice the square on c5
that would give a check and it would
potentially fork another piece
so rook f2 rook f2 is what i played
rook takes f2 now queen c5 we take on f2
and i'm simply a pawn up
and his king is very weak and i went on
to win
so it's not entirely what i wanted to
illustrate
but it does show you that sometimes oh
my god it
ain't gifted what is this man doing
damn girl you literally just gifted 38
subs
oh my god who is this guy
this is awesome thank you so much for
another eight subs now he has officially
gifted 38
and he keeps the hype train going and
captain cola jumping in with five subs
to the community oh my god
this is crazy this is sunday morning
craziness the bribes going
all around all right
thank you captain caller for the five
what's up fukazi
all right uh we're trying to fund your
year off to focus on chess indeed well i
don't
i don't mind that one bit
all right so back to the game i think
this is a similar kind of idea right
you're not doing anything crazy
you're just taking the pawn and uh and
attacking kind of slowly even though
quote unquote you're down a piece
okay um any questions about
the game because once he played queen e3
king h1 the game is over he resigned
here
after rook h7 we'd simply take on d7 and
then play e6
or take on d5
[Music]
you